you know his spirit lives on in
everything that we do and really excited
that is our exclusive look at bindi
Irwin 'z wedding special it airs
tomorrow on Animal Planet and of course
was a bittersweet occasion without
bindis dad Steve there but she always
finds the beauty in life and et knows
that because we've been with Steve
Irwin's little girl since she truly was
a little girl
her name's bindi and we called a bindi
after the feistiest female crocodile
that I've got at my zoo and so I reckon
bindi is gonna follow in my footsteps we
first met bindi back when she was just
three years old and she was always a
daddy's girl do you mind if we keep you
come on you
this was the Irwin's entrance riding on
top of an elephant to the big movie
premiere of the Crocodile Hunter hi EJ
here we go I like but for bindis walked
down the aisle
it's brother Robert who's her escort the
wedding location Australia Zoo where she
grew up we live in the middle of the zoo
so I'm very lucky we every morning you
don't need an alarm clock because you'll
hear the birds and tigers and elephants
so it's a lot of fun what's the one
thing dad would have wanted he would
have wanted me to be happy
bindi and Chandler Powell's intimate
ceremony included handwritten vows and
this special candle in honor of dad I
wish I wish so much that dad and
Chandler could have met what do you
think Dad would have thought of that
great guy oh I I hope you'd like to him
I think he would I don't know what do
you think mom I think I think he's great
I think I think your dad would have
tested him yeah morning noon and night
and then approved
[Music]